traditionnellement les banques centrales
et notamment les grandes banques
centrales occidentales allaient une part
très importante de la réserve en or
elles les ont conservé les nouvelles
banques centrales de tous les pays qui
ont émergé et la turquie ont en fait
partie non pas eu ces héritages aussi
important et donc quelque part ils
essaient de reconstituer leurs réserves
d'or la chine fait pareil on est dans ce
champ l'irrationnel qui faisait
autrefois les français aimait bien avoir
un lagon ou éventuellement même un
napoléon qui leur permettait de croire
que finalement il avait un actif solide
et ça ça parle à quelque part aux gens
et je pense que air dogan et la turquie
sont un peu dans cette logique il y as
probablement de meilleurs moyens
d'utiliser les réserves turques
aujourd'hui que d'acheter de l'or